me avisas y empezamos a grabar me avisa tomis isleán que ya estamos grabando es decir que esto que
están ustedes viendo es el inicio oficial de la tercera temporada del método puede ser algunos
anuncios de rigor en principio si me están viendo mejor no es solo porque yo año a año cada vez
me veo mejor eso es una parte de la realidad la otra es que hemos sido iluminados por foto
No sé si lo ven. Hay una nueva apuesta escénica.
en el método, que además va a ir mejorando con el tiempo, porque Photo Experience es la
casa de fotografía número uno del país. Eso es algo que también la gente tiene que saberlo.
Perdón, Tommy, ¿qué me hiciste?
Que tiene cursos.
Ah, pero Tommy, me extraña. Si estamos hablando de Photo Experience, estamos en sus cursos,
sus profesionales, sus profesores. Básate que si me vuelte eso, que no te escucho porque...
No, no, link en la descripción.
Y hay, por supuesto, link en la descripción para las personas que quieran adquirir los
productos de foto experience lo van a poder hacer.
va a ser un poco más así este año. Hay más chivos, hay más cosas que se van a ir enterando.
Yo, en este momento, estoy exultante de felicidad.
Bueno, no parece.
No parece, estoy más serio todavía.
Si la gente exultante suele estar a los saltos, suele ser...
¿Qué es una felicidad más estática?
Especialmente en los medios, ¿no?
Sí.
El hombre mediático está muy preocupado de que se le note su felicidad,
o en todo caso, de transmitir una felicidad que acaso no siente.
Entonces, alta, gesticula, exagera.
mueve las manos cuando llena la música.
ese tipo de cosas. Bueno, pero acá tenemos, como vos habrás notado, un ensamble más,
uno dice medio y uno piensa en medios, no sé si piensa en el método. El método es casi una
pime, te diría, es una intendencia familiar con acomodos, nepotismo, todo.
Y está muy bien también.
desde, no sé, tener 16 años y leer crónicas del Ángel Gris, ¿viste?
Entonces, hay algo que a mí se me juegan esto, por eso digo, es una confesión de
parte para que sepas con qué contas del otro lado. A mí se me juega, no sólo una
responsabilidad frente a quien esté mirando, que es menor, me importa un poco
menos, pero sí a quién fui, ¿viste? Hay un joven de 16 años que me está en este
momento tomando punto de lo que hago.
¿Y vos crees que ese joven tiene autoridad moral sobre ti?
Uff, quizás es quien más la tiene.
Yo creo lo contrario, yo era una persona tan poco recomendable cuando tenía 16 años
que en verdad soy yo el que está continuamente jugando a aquel chico que fui.
¿Lo lograste revertir entonces eso?
Como decía Homero Mansi en un poema no muy conocido, él decía si yo tuviera 10 años, bla, bla, bla.
y dice, entonces...
El niño que hay en mi hombría mataría al hombre que hubo en mi niñez.
Excelente.
Y es verdad que muchos de nosotros en forma precoz
hemos contraído una cierta condición de canallas que después cuesta toda una vida lijar.
Depurarlas, Capas, también.
Puede ser, yo capaz lo asociaba a...
Quizás hay algo en la juventud, en esos primeros momentos, o en mi caso al menos,
como estas ínfulas de grandeza, de moralidad, de búsqueda, de los propósitos grandes,
que yo lo he encontrado, por ejemplo, en tu literatura, en tus premisas, en esas cosas,
que me parece que una vez es...
Siento que le rinde cuentas a ese niño, a esa persona que uno dijo que el que quiere
ser cuando seas grande, ¿viste? ¿Vos te pasa que vos de chico querías ser el
dolina que eso soy, por ejemplo? Yo de chico quería ser todo, de manera que era fatal que
algún sueño se cumpliera. Yo quería ser todo, era muy hospitalario con mis sueños.
Entonces tenía yo un umbral en mi casa de la niñez, donde me sentaba.
con un pedazo de pan con manteca y azúcar.
Buenísimo.
Es un manjar que ahora es inaccesible al gusto de nuestro tiempo.
Y pensaba cosas.
A ver, ¿qué querías?
Se lo pensaba seriamente.
Por ahí andaban colectiveros, por ejemplo.
pero también estaba periodista, digo pero también como si yo fuera periodista no lo logré, no
quise finalmente hacerlo, pero ahí estaba un poco todo, parecía... no es que estaba eligiendo,
no, no estaba preparándome a recibir lo imprevisible y así fue, así fue, me hice.
anhelos, mis vocaciones se desarrollaron de manera imprevisible.
Y lograste muchas. O sea, de hecho, algo que te quería preguntar es para vos, yo creo que
sos un artista, porque vos podés escribir, vos podés hacer radio, vos podés entretener,
vos podés hacer reír, podés hacer música. Eso tiene cierto riesgo, ¿viste? La posibilidad
de hacer un todo es como un malabarista chino. O sea, capaz hay muchos platillos al mismo
tiempo.
quisiera que la lista no fuera tan extensa, porque si no tendrían razón mis tías que
decían, que el que mucho abarca, etcétera. Y sin embargo ha venido a darme la razón,
cierta situación que se da en el posmodernismo, que es que hay una articulación de distintas
habilidades que quizá no existía antes.
Y hoy no estoy seguro de que baste un mero pianista.
Hay que articularlo con alguna otra cosa.
Y esa característica de la posmodernidad, de algún modo,
me evita las recriminaciones de mis tías.
Pero no así las medidas.
que creo que, efectivamente, en alguna de estas disciplinas no puede alcanzar la preparación
correspondiente.
O sea, ¿te vino bien el aura posmoderna para poder excusarte un poquito de ciertas definiciones?
Sí, está bien eso.
Puedo admitir que tiene cierta gracia, pero a mí me hubiera gustado ser un poco más
si extra en alguna de estas disciplinas, pero a lo mejor...
El riesgo de esa profundización hubiera sido tener que borrar alguna.
Claro, lógicamente.
En el que borrar algunos cariños, claro.
¿Hay alguna que vos digas?
Yo soy más esto y a veces incursión o...
Escribir, seguramente.
Escribir.
Sí, pues yo me preparo para eso, sí.
O sea, es segunda confesión.
A mí me pasa algo con la literatura.
Yo me auto-percibo un escritor.
El tema es que no tengo evidencias para comprobarlo.
O sea, no puedo agarrar y decir, miren lo que escribí.
No tengo nada, me cuesta.
Estoy tratando de escribir en este momento.
No está bien.
Llevo a su tiempo.
Me parece muy difícil.
Pero, ¿qué tiene que ver con él?
Me parece, lo hablaba a la vez...
Pero está bien que lo sientas como difícil.
¿Está bien?
Es que es peligroso creer que algo es fácil.
Imagínate, un agarre y se puede escribir lo primero que le sale
y como ya he recibido el todo uno que es fácil,
piensa que debe salir esa dificultad.
Y entonces se contenta con lo primero que sale.
Yo creo que el...
La virtud de un escritor recibe mucho en su propia desconfianza.
El escritor tiene ese desconfiado.
Así empieza a leer de nuevo, a fijarse si todas las palabras apuntan para el mismo lado.
Vamos, es corregir.
El escritor que está demasiado confiado, que tiene muchos amigos que le dicen que es genial,
Enseguida se contenta con...
con lo que ha hecho.
¿Y a vos te pasa escribiendo que capaz te peleas con el texto
con lo que escribí?
Sí, me pego con todo.
Yo sufro mucho cuando escribo porque no logro lo que quiero.
Y entonces ahí estoy peleándome,
consultando, borrando, repintiéndome.
hasta que después vienen mis editores y me amenazan con...
un juicio tremendo, entonces ahí voy y publico cosas como esa.
Muy bueno, muy bueno, o a vos, o a vos no te parece.
No, a mí me parece que me parece que está bien.
Mal haría yo en decir, no, me parece que no, o pierda bien.
Me parece que puedo hacer algo mejor que eso.
Bueno, si puedes hacer algo mejor, porque no lo haces.
Hacelo. Hacelo, que vas a menos.
No, eso es lo mejor que yo puedo hacer.
Esto es lo mejor.
Sí, lo mejor que se puede hacer.
Todo es lo mejor que yo pueda hacer, lamento decir.
Si pudiera hacer algo mejor, pues lo haría.
Bueno, eso es excelente también, o sea, haber ido a fondo,
tener como la certeza de decir, acá yo hice lo mejor.
Esto de yo, sí.
No se trata de mucho más que eso, en última instancia.
Claro, claro.
Yo me pasa vista a veces escribiendo que me cuesta mucho
que algo resista a mi propio juicio pasado el tiempo.
A veces siento que estoy en un racha de inspiración
y lo elevo a los dos meses y digo, esto es genial.
¿Tiene miedo al juicio de los demás?
al juicio de los académicos.
Mira, los académicos menos porque mezcudo también en algo que me gusta mucho,
algo que decía Macedonio Fernández,
viste, sobre el academicismo extenuante de la época, que él quería ser una legato
propación en contra de como agarrar y romper esas cosas, viste.
Esas cosas me inspiran a mí, me encantaría...
esto ya es muchísimo. Me encantaría poder formar parte de la
constelación de aquello a lo que admiro, ¿viste? Ya es como un montón. Pero en esas
personas, en esas personas que un poco se cagan en esas cosas, yo encuentro
admiración y empatía. Entonces, si vos me decís, los académicos no sé. Yo creo que
para los académicos yo voy a escribir mal, yo creo que escribo mal por eso.
Me gusta que hago todo esto sin tener nada, para vosotros tengo un papel escrito, es todo abstracto.
Pero está bien decidir ser escritor,
autopersibirse como un escritor,
antes de escribir.
Exacto.
e
Voy a las reuniones de la S.A.D., me postulo para las listas en sus elecciones internas
y contesto cuando me preguntan en la calle la policía que soy escritor. Ya tendré
tiempo a escribir. Exactamente. Te mentiría si te dijera, no, no me importa lo que digan,
me importa lo que digan algunas personas. Entonces, ¿por qué me da miedo la escritura?
yo siento que me expone de verdad.
Te soy completamente honesto. ¿Hacer esto, por ejemplo?
Esto, para mí, tiene como un grado de facilidad mayor,
lo siento más natural, lo siento...
Perentorio, lo siento como...
Pero es más fácil.
Más fácil.
La radio es extraordinaria.
Nosotros vamos a un horario todos los días,
hay unos amigos, nos rellemos un poco.
Seguimos el tono, hay una conversa.
Es más fácil conversar que escribir la divina comedia.
¡Vamos!
¿Y la escritura? No, la escritura no tiene eso, tiene en principio una soledad aterradora
y una complejidad, finalmente, que es mayor que está de conversar y de armar más o menos
bien el sujeto si predicados.
Exacto, en el libro de hecho se juega lo mismo que de si es vos, en el libro si yo hago un
proceso, lo concluyo, lo termino, lo publico, de verdad significa que es lo mejor que puedo
¡Muchas gracias!
Y ahí sí, si a la persona que me importa su opinión me dice,
la verdad que es una cagada lo que hiciste,
eso es de verdad donde intente ir a fondo.
Claro.
Y ahí mostrarás las costillas,
yo siento eso, que la escritura te desnuda en serio.
La radio estaba haciendo un chiste, bueno,
fue un programa de una vez, qué sé yo.
Creo que la radio es así, tiene una...
Libia Andá, que le es inerente, pero está bien.
No está bien.
¿Cómo vences ese temor, entonces, escribiendo?
como
No, no, no se ven, sí. ¿Para qué hay que vencer?
No se ven, sí. ¿Para qué hay que vencer temores?
Pues ya pasa con miedo.
Es espectacular.
Hay que...
A las cosas más graves de la vida hay que diron que se ha muerto de miedo.
Si uno espera vencer los temores,
a veces tiene que esperar edades
tan provectas como para que uno ni siquiera tenga miedo.
Si es mejor ir con el miedo juvenil que uno tiene, a que lo destruyan.
Es que lo revienten, digamos.
No tiene más miedo, con el más joven tiene mucho más que perder.
¿Vos a qué edad escribiste crónicas del Ángel Gris?
Ah, yo no me sigo, yo me he muerto que era el mismo, me he muerto que era el mismo.
Y esa fue, o sea...
No, pero eso ya lo había escrito.
Las crónicas del ángel gris son una recopilación de textos
que yo había escrito para la revista Humor en casi todos los casos
y como ejercicio privado en otros.
De manera que al publicarse el libro los textos ya tenían como 10 años.
Ah, claro.
En algunos casos, ¿no?
así que puede haberlos escrito a los 30.
Y lo publicé, creo, a los 40, me pareció un poquito más, tal vez.
Yo no estaba muy interesado en publicar libros.
Yo fue una ocurrencia de Andrés Casión y me hubo que tener que hacer un libro con estas crónicas,
que tenés que hacer un libro.
realmente se publicó y carrizo antonio me dijo
algo que me gustó cuando examinó el libro.
Y, si bueno, te diste cuenta, pero hace escrita una novela,
estas crónicas donde se repitan personajes,
donde se van trazando algunas líneas en sus conductas,
donde hay unos ciertos ribores que aparecen a lo largo
de todos los artículos que parecen,
en principio parecen diferentes.
Yo creo que dijo Antonio, que son una novela, creo que tenía razón.
Tienen algo de federalismo, esos artículos,
en la medida en que tienen su independencia propia
y, sin embargo, pertenecen a un corpus más grande y superior.
¿Y ese libro, vos, por ejemplo, decís,
no tenías interés en publicar o en escribir libros?
¿Ahí no eras un escritor o sí, lo que vos...
¡Mira como vos!
Sí, yo escribía cuentos. Yo escribía, había escrito algunos cuentos y desde luego las cosas que se publicaban en la revista Humor
tenían a mi juicio un contenido mucho más literario que periodístico, eran ficcionales.
no hablaban mal de los cantores ni cosa progresiva.
Lógico. Y te pasa, por ejemplo, creo que esto te lo escucho decir en algún lado,
indudablemente hay un recorrido desde Crónica del Ángel Gris hasta ahora,
lo que vos podés publicar ahora. Sí, sí.
A vos te pasa que relees aquel libro y te gusta o agarrás, si decís, me esto...
No sé, no lo relego mucho, pero sí, lo hago a veces.
No me gustan tanto, ¿no? No me gustan tanto como estos que escribo ahora, porque hay algunos ingenuidades,
hay otras exageraciones propias del artista joven que tiene ganas de escribir todas las palabras que sabes.
Pero bueno, tampoco reniego, no me arrepiento de los escritos, no sé qué está bien.
No, claro, lo repenticen de cosas. Ojalá no te arrepentir eso, ¿por qué?
A veces puede ser que uno haya escrito verdadera gilada.
En el que caso no, tal vez yo no soy tampoco mucho más astuto ahora.
Ok. A mí, por ejemplo, la impresión una, una, sí, para hablar de esa hora en particular.
Voy a hacer una segunda cita a Macedonio, no hay muchas personas a quienes yo puedo decirle esto, pero...
Yo, con la categoría, hombres sensibles, refutadores de leyendas, es algo que a mí me legó un prisma para vivir mi propia vida, ¿viste?
Y yo creo que eso acá viene... en realidad no, no es cita Macedo, ni es cita Borges, que agarra y dice, creo que la he imitado hasta el más de voto plagio.
Yo veo una evolución desde eso.
no sé si llamarlo evolución, ¿sabes cuál es la sanción que me dio cuando leía notas al pie?
que esta...
la escritura está acosada
por cosas más terribles
el notas al pie tiene algo que yo no sé si esto debería ser una advertencia editorial, no sé por qué me meto en esto con Planeta
o con Planeta, pero
los papeles sueltos
¡Que aparecen cada tanto!
Algunos son una patada al pecho, que uno no ve venir, me acuerdo, puntualmente en este momento, dos, hay uno que, si no me equivoco, se llama fantasmas y es que uno sin advertirlo está rodeado de todos los momentos de personas que conoció y amó en su vida, decirlo, me conmueve.
Y otro que es aterrador, que es una pesadilla que va relatando como la pesadilla de un niño,
eso es otra cosa que admiro de tu pluma, creo que vos tenés una de las mejores literaturas
que evocan la ternura de la infancia. Hay algo de narrar perspectivas de niños que yo,
que soy una persona que creo que se enreda mucho para hablar y termina hablando difícil,
gran crítica de mi viejo, ya que estoy que lo puedo citar, que siempre que le he mostrado
algo me dijo, hablás difícil al pedo, es como un rechazo, así, in totum, viste.
¡Suscríbete!
Es como si hay mensajes con un nivel de ternura y de pureza en esa infancia
que en este libro se conjugan con de repente despertar y descubrir que tenés 60 años,
tus viejos murieron hace ya mucho tiempo y es una serie de pesadillas sucesivas y de despertar.
Es terrible, señor, hasta que en el último de despertar el niño ya no es un niño y su padre ya no está ganado.
todo el mundo que venía preocupándolo en el texto anterior, había desaparecido,
y esto era todavía mucho peor.
¡Peor!
Lo que parecía, sí, sí.
Es peor y me dio como miedo, ¿viste?
Y yo lo que veo es...
me parece que tu obra como gran parte de lo que para mí es una tradición hasta
del río de la plata, de sensibles del río de la plata, está atravesada por creer,
¿viste? creer, pues si uno cree o si no cree, en cualquier nivel, si cree que las
cosas van en la pena, que no van en la pena, y este libro se puso peligroso, o sea,
crónica del ángel gris a mí me hizo sentir bien, feliz, me hizo sentir, eh,
Dios, qué lindo que es todo, este es difícil.
Y te quería preguntar con todo un recorrido a cuestas,
¿viste? De si tu propia perspectiva del creer se ha modificado.
Claro que sí. Yo nunca he sido muy creyente ni muy optimista,
Pero entre las crónicas y este libro, hay 30 años.
Ya es el paso del tiempo ya suficiente para inculcarnos a un cierto pesimismo, ¿no?
Pero de todos modos a mí me parece que el pesimismo está considerado como una especie de mal humor insoportable de personas a agua fiesta.
Ay, parece que no. Se puede ser pesimista y sin embargo bailar arriba de las mesas.
¿Lo que hay?
Es que a mí me gusta que mientras bailamos sobre la mesa,
mientras yo de la música de los carnovales,
mientras disfrutamos un ambiente incluso orgiástico,
alguien me mire y me diga con la mirada,
atención que no me olvide de nada.
Pero es terrible
La alegría del que sabe que se va a morir, del que sabe que es mortal, de que conoce que la naturaleza humana es trágica y sin embargo se divierte, y sin embargo se divierte, y sin embargo compone milongas y baila tomando al tipo de adelante de la cintura.
Bueno, en algún punto es más poderosa también, porque es valiente.
Así dice Nietzsche, en el primer capítulo de el nacimiento de la tragedia, que él admira muchísimo a los griegos
y que siendo como fueron los griegos del pueblo más admirado, más hermoso, más inteligente.
de la historia y de la antigüedad,
fueron ellos los que crearon la tragedia.
Fueron ellos los que hicieron algo
que no necesitaba esconder ni eludir el final trágico de ser humano.
El contrario, lo mostraron descarnadamente y con eso se divertía.
iban a ver eso, se complacían en eso, obtenían un gozo en leer esas cosas y enverlas y en
representarlas y el opina entonces que no es verdad que los pueblos
valientes generan historias con finales felices.
En realidad, la verdadera Valentina del arte griego está
en comprender la naturaleza trágica de la naturaleza humana
y mostrarla y disfrutar con eso.
No inventando cuentos de ahadas con finales en que todos nos
encontraremos.
O sea, es bailarle en la cara al abismo, digamos.
Claro.
¡Muchas gracias!
Un poco compadres esa actitud, ¿no?
Hay algo, hay un desafío ahí.
Sábato le llama a Dan Vismo eso, ¿no?
En otro ejemplo, no tan parecido a este,
pero que es de la misma colección,
el que, estando libre de pecado, no arroja la primera piedra.
A ver, ¿cómo sería eso?
Claro. El que esté libre de pecado decía al Cristo que arroje la primera piedra.
Y él decía que una actitud de Dandis como era estar libre de pecado y sin embargo no arrojar ninguna piedra.
Claro.
y se parece también a esta actitud del arte griego de no querer engañarse de ninguna manera acerca de lo trágico de su naturaleza.
no comprar ninguna, ningún cuento de consuelo.
Pareciera que eso puede, o sea, si es que se le puede asignar función al arte,
o sea que alguna utilidad tiene miles, pero si uno pudiera extraer como su esencia.
A veces pareciera que el arte, término más acralizado no sé si hay,
pero se trata un poco de eso, como de humanidad en estado puro,
como si uno pudiera insectar su humanidad.
Pero además el arte, si es que hay que buscar una utilidad, además de eso, que es una justificación ética y estética.
El arte sirve para no morirse, en el caso del hombre.
Si, si ser humano es decirlo mejor, no...
No tuviera poesía ni romance ni belleza en su vida, se moriría antes, su vida sería
peor y así como se necesitan ojos, cerebro, oídos para ver, para escuchar y para anticipar
y modificar el entorno, también se necesita la posibilidad de reconocer la belleza, de
para disfrutarme de crear la llegada del caso.
y el que lo que tiene vive peor, se muere antes, se extingue.
Bueno, vos has tenido como la...
Yo creo que has creado belleza.
Eso para mí es un montón, en términos de contribución a la humanidad.
Bueno, muchas gracias.
Por favor.
Yo no estoy tan seguro tampoco.
No, sí, sí, sí, yo te lo afirmo. Si vos no estás seguro.
Alguien se lo tiene que afirmar a otra persona y así perpetra...
A mí me lo dicen a veces, pero no les creo.
No les creo.
Yo creo que vos, independientemente de mi opinión, al menos has podido dedicarte a
hacer eso, ¿no? Has hecho una carrera de...
Sí, claro. Sí, sí, sí.
Y me imagino...
Pero no haces un privilegio, también. Imagínate vos en un mundo en donde es difícil ganarse
el sustento, poder hacerlo mediante una actividad tan luminosa, tan gozosa. Es un privilegio.
y
privilégio que hay que agarpar,
haciéndolo lo mejor que no pueda,
como hemos dicho antes.
Hay tal deber también, ¿no?
Sí, claro.
Y no sé si llamarle deber, pero algo así.
¿Y una responsabilidad segura?
Ya que te pagan por escribir,
tratas de hacerlo bien dentro de tus posibilidades.
¿Qué significa tratas de hacerlo bien?
Empecé a leer lo que escriben otros, a ver si aprendes algo.
Sí.
posible que escriba después de esto, ¿eh? Yo creo que sí. No, pero si estás leyendo,
ya se ha empezado a escribir, pero primero que hay que hacer es leer, aunque hay gente
que no pasa de esa primera etapa, pero esa primera etapa es muy venturosa, la lectura,
más venturosa que la escritura.
¿Vos recordás un momento donde, vos laburaste varias cosas en tu vida, un momento donde
te diste cuenta, ché, estoy empezando a poder dedicarme a lo que amo, si es que esos son
tus términos, un momento como de conciencia decir, ché, lo logré, ché.
Sí, pero fue difícil.
¿Por qué?
¿Por qué es muy complicado?
La vida está llena de falsas apariencias, de señales contrarias,
de ambientes en los que uno empieza a construir un edificio que no es el que quería construir.
Uno por ahí está rodeado de personas con otros intereses,
por ahí tan valiosos como los propios, pero distintos.
Todo es muy difícil eso.
En algún momento...
Yo me di cuenta que había encontrado,
voy a ser específico y casi técnico,
que había encontrado algo parecido,
no sé si es un estilo, pero sí a una entonación propia.
Y que fue cuando yo trabajaba en la revista Humor
y me encargaban notas cada 15 días.
Yo no cumplía casi nunca.
Me atrasaba, me costaba mucho, ¿no?
Entonces mandaban un tipo, yo trabajaba como redactor publicitario
y Casioli mandaba a uno de sus empleados
a la oficina donde ya trabajaba de redactor publicitario
con orden de no regresar si no era con la nota.
Excelente.
Entonces el tipo separaba atrás, yo empezaba a escribirla o continuaba escribiéndola
Y por ahí decía, bueno, decíle que mañana se le entrego, no decí el ritmo.
Me dijo que no me fuera hasta que no me la di.
¿Se la extraían a la fuerza, o sea, a la nota?
Bueno, me la extraían al recuerdo.
Pero ahí, de tanto no tener ideas, de tanto querer cumplir sin poder hacerlo,
se me inculió que podía utilizar algunas cosas que yo había escrito
con una intención más artística.
Y que tenía guardadas. Yo tenía guardado algunos cuentos,
incluso una especie de proyecto de novelas que tenía ahí en unos cuadernos.
Y claro, como no se me ocurría nada, tomaba algunos,
empecé a tomar algunos de esos fragmentos, los difrasaba,
le daba una forma asalística quizá, y se los mandaba a Casioli.
¡Excelente!
Y un día dije, no, pero es esto lo que yo tengo que hacer.
Porque ahí estaba yo.
Quiero decir, sentí que era una entonación propia.
Qué es lo más que uno, a lo que uno puede aspirar.
Cada escriptor no puede ser una revolución.
Algo que nunca se ha hecho, no.
Afán de originalidad no conducía nada.
pero
tener apenas por un rato un asento propio, eso se puede, y ahí es donde por casualidad lo conseguí, creo.
¿Y vos esas cosas las escribías para vos, o sea las tenías?
Aquellas que yo estaba saqueando las escribí para mí, en su momento, sí, sí.
eran cuentos, historias, todas ficcionales.
Las di vuelta, les añadí un relato.
completamente hay uno de adjetivos y de énfasis y resultó, resultó bien.
Metodológicamente es excelente, ¿eh?
Claro, bueno, es muy borgeano eso. Borges aconsejaba el pudor por los énfasis,
ejercer una una tarea de vigilancia muy fuerte sobre el texto propio para que...
No, no fuera enfático, para que no aparecieran palabras que parecían escritas en rojo, diríamos.
Ahí, por ejemplo, bueno, Borges también dice que en realidad no la voy a citar bien,
pero que todo destino consta en realidad un solo momento, que es el momento en el que el hombre sabe para siempre quién es, ¿no?
Quizás es muy barroco esto, pretender tenerlo así en la vida, ¿no?
Como un rayo que te extraquea, pero vos tenés algún momento en tu vida donde dijiste,
¿Este es quien soy?
Apenas tuve esa intuición profesional.
¿En este momento ahí que describiso?
No, no es esa intuición profesional que te acabo de contar.
Lo otro es mucho pedir para mí, que es yo quien soy.
No lo sé.
Bueno, yo creo que nadie es nadie, decís ahí en algún momento.
Yo creo que nadie.
Esa estaba bien.
Imagínense.
La gente está todo el tiempo tratando de ser alguien para luego decirlo.
Entonces se compra el anuario de Orangel y se fija a ver qué dice del signo, del zodíaco, el cual pertenece.
Y empieza, a falta de otro dato, empieza a creer en eso.
Tauro dice, los de Tauro son tenaces, perseveran en las cosas que hacen, dice el tipo.
Ese soy yo. Claro que sos vos alguna vez, hasta que de golpe no sos eso, sino otra cosa.
Y...
El tipo está contento con eso, y si no encuentran eso,
pero hay alguien que dice algo y él opta por creerlo.
Y está tratando, incluso con preferencias,
el tipo trata de construirse.
No, yo, por ejemplo, no provebo el pollo.
Y mira, como diciendo, andás llevando, porque esto es yo, que no pruebo el pollo,
y se busca, yo lo he visto en persona, he visto gente buscar dentro de sí,
alguna particularidad para luego decirla en la mesa y quedar,
como verdaderamente alguien personal.
Sí.
Es infructoso todo eso, es mentira lo que dice,
es mentira que no le gusta el pollo y qué clase de ser.
y capaz el tipo estuvo pensando toda la semana.
Sí, capaz el tipo estuvo pensando toda la semana, con esto los mato, no me gusta el pollo.
Miro, con esto los mato, o yo, por ejemplo, no me hablo con los vecinos, ni sé, mira.
Trebendo.
Sí, o yo esto y yo aquello, basta. Basta. Basta.
es mucho mejor para buscarse incluso uno mismo, mirar al otro, mirar al otro.
y ponerle al yo distintos adjetivos, según el foro en donde estés tomando un helado,
es medio difícil.
¿Dónde te encontrás, por ejemplo? Imagino que te buscás.
Sí, claro, pero no siempre, me encuentro, ¿qué sé yo? Me encuentro en la duda.
En la duda siempre me encuentro, me encuentro a mí, me encuentro a las personas que amo.
Allí en la duda uno encuentra amigos, me puse en...
en el convencimiento es más difícil, ¿por qué? Porque compartir la duda, la perplejidad
ante un mundo muy complejo y difícil de percibir, compartir eso se parece a lo que es la amistad.
La amistad es una búsqueda compartida, búsqueda de la gloria, quizá búsqueda...
de la respuesta a algunas preguntas, por ejemplo, quién somos, quiénes somos, ¿no?
Y ahí está la amistad.
Pero lo otro, mostrarse continuamente uno,
ante otro, eso no se parece a la amistad,
se parece a las charlas de la gente que van a tomar algo al día del amigo.
Es más como si uno mostras un catálogo de uno mismo, mirá mis cualidades.
Y pero es fácil ese catálogo, es fácil, ¿qué es eso?
No lo sé. Pero uno no es todos los días ese.
Bueno, Whitman, ¿no? Que contengo multitud, es que es verdad, ¿verdad?
Y a veces ni siquiera son multitud, son dos o tres.
Linda Whitman, ¿eh?
¿Eh?
te pasa que no te quiero preguntar por no sabes que de qué quiero hablar de esto
vos citaste en un momento dijiste no citaste dijiste que la pretensión de
originalidad era algo no sé si hace quible viste pero está ahí y
recuerdo haberte escuchado probablemente de joven de más joven
decir que todo todo escritor argentino es un intento de imitación de Borges no que
Un punto ahí.
Yo también, claro. Yo tengo la sensación, porque para mí Borges es la mejor pluma de
la República Argentina, es decir, es que el mejor ejecutó algo, hasta técnicamente,
pero hace no tanto, harán unos 4 o 5 años, descubría Macedonio, ¿no? Lo descubrí casi
por accidente, porque estaba leyendo el hombre que está solo y espera.
Y Escalabriní lo trafica, este lo tira ahí como el único metafísico de la Ciudad de Buenos Aires.
Y digo, ¿qué es esto? ¿Qué hay acá?
Y me embarqué en leer, no todas vigílias, de los ojos abiertos, que es un camino de ida porque te descompone molecularmente.
De repente vos te mirás y no entendés, te empezás a salir flotando, digamos.
Pero sin embargo esos textos son mejores usados por Borges.
Bueno, eso es increíble.
A mí me da la sensación de que es como si Macedonio fuera una suerte de fuente,
como si fuese una fuente en estado puro y que todos fueron a mamar de ahí,
pero quizás su mejor traductor fue Borges, porque Borges puede agarrar eso y decir que esto no se entiende nada.
Te lo ordeno así.
¿Qué te parece así?
¿Qué te parece si lo hacemos por este lado?
completamente de acuerdo con ese íctame.
¿Hay una tradición, y ahí veo que es una tradición literaria en la República Argentina,
que puede tener o su origen o no en esa dirección?
Porque son varios los macedonianos, si uno quiere hacer una...
Es difícil hablar de una tradición literaria en una literatura tan joven y tan varios pintas como la literatura argentina.
Ahí, de nuevo está la literatura cauchésca, está.
El camino trazado por Borges, están talugones, como un farola iluminándolo todo, como un farol alarmante.
Un farol tremendo, es un farol terrible también.
Y esas son caminos diferentes de lo literario.
está, desde luego, Cortázar, ¿no?
La más, incluso más parecida al gusto de este tiempo.
A Muncho le gusta más Cortázar que Borges.
¿Vos cómo ves esa, viste, que uno tiene esta tendencia
de comparaciones que existen?
¿Pero qué te pasa con estos autores? ¿Te gusta más Cortázar?
No, claro, me pasa que no...
No, no, no los considero de esa manera.
Claro. No es que me gusten más uno que otro nuevo.
No, para qué perdérselo, solo por comparar.
Lo que puede ser que uno quiera más a uno, pero es un error también.
¿Es un error?
Por sí, porque a veces por querer o no querer, uno se pierde una gran literatura.
Y ahí viene la gran pregunta, si es que debe perdonarse una actitud incorrecta.
porque un tipo escribe bien, o al revés, si uno debe renunciar a una buena literatura,
porque el tipo es un canalla, y no lo sé, no lo sé.
Disfruto lo que hay, disfruto lo que hay después, cuando hablamos de quiénes,
de si Picasso era uno, era un canalla, es otra conversación.
Son dos conversaciones dites.
pero no sé por qué entre en este tema.
No, igual es así, hay una tendencia metodológica en este espacio
que no hay muchos temas, en eso también es más postmoderno,
puede ser, hay ritos de modernidad, puede ser que Cortázar tenga más que ver
quizás estéticamente con el presente, no lo había pensado así.
Yo no sé si con el presente, tiene más que ver.
no sé si es el presente. A ver. Nos parece que era el presente y a lo mejor esto ya ha cambiado también.
Para los muchachos progresistas, días de 20 años, Cortázar era mejor visto que Borges.
Pero ese no es el presente ahora, cuál es el presente y no lo sé, no lo sé, no lo sé.
¿Cómo vivís vos el presente? ¿Te parece raro?
¿Te parece... Hubo cosas raras, ¿eh?
La verdad que entre pandemia, digitalización de cosas,
sobra motivos para...
Me parece raro pues la única cosa que uno vive.
Lo demás son ficciones.
Sí.
El pasado y el futuro son construcciones que uno hace
generalmente incorrectas.
Últimamente estoy frecuentando
a unos compañeros del colegio.
y no estoy seguro de que sean una buena compañía para mí.
¿A ver?
Lo digo arriba, lo digo sabiendo que ellos no van a estar escuchando.
Acá no... Acá a no irte...
Y suelen darme ellos una visión del pasado y del presente muy tendenciosa y muy peligrosa.
Peligrosa.
Peligrosa, sí.
¿Por qué?
¿Por qué han hecho renuncia de algunas condiciones?
Estoy pensando si decir lo que hubiera.
Pero sí, hay muchas personas que siendo muy inteligentes y muy preparadas, creen que corresponde
a personas de cierta edad un renunciamiento, un renunciamiento a las esperanzas, especialmente
a lo que es sensual, a lo que tiene que ver con el disfrute de los sentidos.
y entonces se han anulado como sujetos deseantes,
porque sienten la mirada acusadora del resto de la sociedad.
Sienten que por tener más de 60 años ya no pueden desear,
ni pueden formular juicios relacionados con ese deseo,
con la apreciación de la belleza.
¿Y esa renuncia?
los modifican, les impide adquirir la tonicidad que es indispensable para contemplar la belleza.
Cuando digo la belleza digo todo, digo lo que es sensual, lo que es intelectual, entonces
los tipos están como anulados, miran mucho la televisión, comparten en las redes sociales
¡Miríos chistosos!
a razón de uno cada media hora y renuncian básicamente al sinismo,
visto este como la capacidad de rastrear el desatino.
Es decir, han perdido un poco de consistencia y de atención.
El tipo que desea, está atento.
A ver, a ver dónde pasa algo que venga a alojarse en mi cerebro y que desate una serie de raciones, reacciones químicas, que te la volio a oír.
El que no tiene eso, mira incluso, para otro lado pensando, no sea cosa que estos tipos
que están acá mirándome, me vean deseando.
Eso es responsabilidad del desciante que renuncia,
pero también del entorno, del entorno que censura el deseo.
Y eso es algo que se relaciona con muchísimos de los temas
que están flotando en el aire, en la discusión del día a día,
en la sociedad en que vivimos hoy.
Tiene mucho que ver.
con ciertas discriminaciones, vamos a usar la palabra, finalmente.
En ese grupo vos que encontras un sparring, la posibilidad de...
No, encuentro que ellos se han rendido en algunas batallas.
Y entonces, son más amables que yo.
¿Son más amables?
Claro, yo no sé si me divierte tanto la gente amable.
Eso no sos un escéptico, entonces.
¿Vos hablaste antes de que no tendías a creer
o que no te llevabas tan bien con creer, quizás?
¿Me parece que alguien que sigue presentando batalla
en los frentes que encuentra no se puede hacer si uno no cree?
Bueno, pero es una batalla...
como la citada anteriormente.
La batalla del que todavía...
No empezó a escribir.
Pero ya empieza a competir con otros escritores, a ver quién es menos.
Claro.
Vos tenés también otra cosa a la que me gustaría hablar, porque esto, o sea,
Hablamos de la escritura, hablamos de su peso específico.
Me mencionaste también cosas de radio, de tu laburo, bóstenes.
Me gustaría afirmar cosas, pero no tengo conocimiento de causa real para decirlas,
pero el ciclo radial que bóstenes no es de los más largos de la historia argentina como ciclo.
Sí, pero es una curiosidad esa.
No solo es una curiosidad.
Una venida arriba de Avian.
Bueno, ¿qué otro mérito tiene esa venida?
Para mí tienen méritos en términos artísticos, intrínsecos, pero también...
La avenida Ribadavia no lo creo.
La mejor, por supuesto, tiene valor cultural, tremendo, uno defiende la avenida Ribadavia donde va.
Yo defendería la venganza, será terrible.
Y yo también, antes que la venía Ribadavia, sí.
En ese orden seguro antes.
No, te quería preguntar si después de tanto tiempo,
¿Cómo uno va encontrando que quizás está relacionado con esto mismo que me dijiste al respecto de...
no rendirse a las posibilidades de estimularse, de sorprenderse, de hacer cosas.
Uno creería la pregunta, me parece que es una pregunta también muy de mi generación,
pero no llega un momento después de hacer algo, no sé, 30 años que te aburre o que agarras
y decís, algún día no vas y decís, chau la pelota.
Si uno hiciera lo mismo durante 30 años, probablemente se aburriría.
Yo no siento que eso sea así.
Lo que se repiten son los horarios.
El lugar donde trabajo, pero el problema es muy distinto lo que era, absolutamente distinto.
Algunas personas han cambiado, es decir, han sido sustituidas por otras y otras han sido sustituidas por ellas mismas.
Eso es lindo.
Es decir, el hombre de hoy sustituye al de hacer.
Lo que quiero decir es que...
Barton no es castelo y yo no soy yo.
Vos sabes que hemos cambiado.
Hay mucha diferencia entre Barton y castelo y mucha más diferencia
entre este que habla con vos y el muchacho que empezó
hace 30 y tantos años en la vengancia.
Si era terrible o demasiado tarde para la grima, como se llamaba.
Es el mismo fenómeno.
entonces hay algo de que no cambiar parecería también renunciar.
a una batalla.
Sí, tampoco hay que creer que todo cambio está bien.
¿Para qué voy a decir eso?
Es algo que...
Ahí está, decir estas cosas.
¿Qué? No, prescindible, le decís.
¿Para qué?
Es una aclaración.
Ahorrar incisos obvios es un arte que yo no posego, evidentemente.
Bueno, eso de vuelta, la literatura, ¿no?
El cambio por el cambio mismo.
No, no vale la pena, ¿qué es eso?
O sea, es cuando hablabas de esto que te pasa con tu grupo de amigos
y decías que hay varias cosas que esto que las ves en términos generales, ¿no?
Yo tengo la impresión de que vivimos tiempos raros, hay tiempos extraños.
Para mí hay mucho de esto que se desprende de que hay una política muy extraña.
Al menos yo le considero un lugar importante de la política viste para determinar.
sociedad, modelo de conducta. En caso de este tiempo, la política es lo más extraño que
sucede. Es muy extraño. Te quería preguntar un poco cómo ves, pero te diría así en
términos generales esto. Yo nunca salgo de una suerte de diagnóstico medio impotente
en términos de lo que uno ve, de representación política, que además tiene como un contraste
muy grande con otras cosas que están pasando, porque de repente vos decís somos campeón
el mundo, ¿no?
campeón del mundo. Algo que ahí, por ejemplo, yo nací en el 93. Yo no pude participar de
ninguna de las hazañas grandes de la historia deportiva de nuestro país, hasta ahora.
Y había una porción de mí que decía, o sea, el otro día lo decía en la radio,
a mi generación se le jugaba que si no era esta, ya nosotros empezamos a contar
para los refutadores de leyendas, porque si a mí no me daba ninguna,
yo pues a ver si miraba, no se puede.
Y esta de repente es como una inyección de creencia impresionante.
Y yo digo, ¿cómo puede estar pasando esto en un lugar del país?
Y vos después ves al mismo tiempo algo tan como como Paco,
como si no se pudiera canalizar esa...
¿Será que a lo mejor la política no tiene algo con el fútbol?
No tiene nada que ver.
Y será.
Es lo primero que a uno se ocurre.
Si la selección consigue un éxito de nivel mundial y todos nos emocionamos y nos sentimos
copartícipes de una alegría popular y por el otro lado vemos de qué lado parece estar
la opinión más oritaria en la política argentina tendríamos que conjeturar que...
Son otras partes del cerebro las que se ocupan del fútbol que las que se ocupan de la política.
¿Y vos crees que la política tampoco puede en causar o representar una esfervescencia, una alegría, un algo?
Puede, como poder puede, no lo está logrando.
No lo está logrando.
Evidentemente, ¿qué es lo que le está pasando al país y al mundo posiblemente?
La desigualdad le está pasando, le está pasando la desigualdad.
A la Argentina le está pasando su pobreza.
No la pobreza considera que un porcentaje de la población
no alcanza a ganarse bien el sustento, sino la pobreza de sus recursos,
ni siquiera sus recursos, la pobreza de su situación actual.
¿Por qué decimos que es un pueblo?
Porque le debemos a cada santo una vela.
Y entonces uno siente la tentación de empezar a hacer
historia, ya que hablábamos de ribadavia,
podríamos ver cuánto mal le hace al país,
Cuanto más pobres, pobres, nos hace ser.
la deuda a que el empréstito de la Bar in Brothers,
que el empréstito de un millón de libras,
que no se necesitaba mucho que digamos,
que tomó Rivadavia junto con sus secuaces,
un millón de libras aquí, ya al principio ya entraban 500.000.
Pero todavía no habíamos contado con las comisiones.
Y esa deuda se terminó a pagar.
Ya en el siglo XX, primeros años del siglo XX, 1905, o sea,
pero mientras tanto, hubo que tomar otros empréstitos para pagar éste.
Y lo que pagó la Argentina durante todo el siglo XIX,
ese resto del siglo XIX, hubiera alcanzado para construir,
de verdad una argentina impresionante.
Y después siguió eso, siguió la historia registra dos gobiernos, tres uno quiere, que no tomaron deuda.
Y entonces cuando uno piensa que es lo que hace que un país sea pobre o sea rico,
Es evidentemente la diferencia que hay entre lo que produce y...
y lo que consume ahora, entre lo que vende y lo que compra,
entre lo que tiene que gastar y lo que tiene disponible para el consumo.
Y claro, si vos se da cuenta, te das idea para no incurrir en un incesto,
de que la mayor cantidad de bienes se gastan en pagar deuda.
Entonces, debe ser muy dañeno esto, debe ser muy dañeno, y esto es histórico, bien.
Está bien que hace unos años tuvo una dimensión inusual, formidable y casi definitiva para los sueños del país.
Ahora, ¿quién no comprenda que el daño está allí?
Y no, en esa idea, aquella metáfora que estuvimos gastando es como una casa que ha gastado demasiado
y después se encuentra con que tiene que pagar. No ha gastado demasiado, no, no.
Una cosa es gastar demasiado y la otra cosa es endeudarse con unos tipos que viven en tu
que hace y son socios de lo que te presta la guita.
y otras cosas y fugarla, que te prestan, y no gastársela en farras que hubiera sido extraordinario.
Por lo menos una joda, ¿eh?
La estuga de farras general de todo el pueblo argentino de cinco años.
No hubo tal cosa, no hubo tal cosa.
Eso es difícil, porque también es cierto que...
Las verdaderas razones de nuestra pobreza están un poquito ocultas por lo contingente.
No ayuda tampoco, no ha sido astuto este gobierno en eludir las numerosas desgracias que le han sucedido.
van desde la pandemia hasta el boicote de la mayoría del pueblo argentino.
Y entonces, lo que flota en el aire es que ya nadie está muy interesado en una política
de inclusión, en un estado que venga a secorrer a los que vienen, a los que menos tienen,
en un estado que sea un poco más rígido, con los que tienen más, poco, nadie mira
con simpatía y eso, ¿no?
Tengo yo de los jugadores de fútbol hablando de fútbol y política.
Están todos indignados porque le van a cobrar altos impuestos por la guita con tanto esfuerzo en ganar.
Ese es muy difícil, es muy difícil.
Yo no estoy interesado en argumentar esto que hice.
No fue un argumento, sino la manera de explicarte.
que es lo que estoy sintiendo, como me parece que los argumentos son absolutamente insuficientes,
insuficientes e impertinentes.
¿Por qué impertinentes?
Porque no son escuchados.
¿Ok?
No se nos escuchamos, porque no es una recusión.
Entonces, un argumento sin pertinente.
Sólo es pertinente a un argumento que no hay una discusión de argumento,
cuando no hay tal cosa que venís vos a decir.
Eh, porque sabe cómo fugaron esa plata, bueno, que sí, me lo explicás.
Sí, si no hay, no hay cauce, no hay...
No hay, te lo escuchas, pero ¿por qué?
Porque ya están convencidos de otra cosa.
Hay un descrédito generalizado.
Sí, es muy difícil luchar contra eso.
Entonces, es...
Hay que empezar a observar la realidad y ver de qué manera la podemos modificar, hay ciertas
recetas que no funcionan, la podemos modificar en qué sentido, el sentido es resolver los
principales problemas que hay aquí, pobreza de nuestros recursos y desigualdad, no solamente
que tenemos poco.
sino que lo distribuimos de un modo desigual.
Siempre que se habla o me parece a mí que se habla de la República Argentina y se
la historiza hay como una tentación de agarrar y decir y los argentinos viste una
historia de conflicto difíciles como que o las salidas fáciles siempre son
esta cosa medio como si fuera aspiracional o inspiracional abstracta del
estilo teniendo todas las posibilidades todos los tenemos todos los clima como que
hay una cosa ahí con el clima, si tenemos todos los clima como puede ser.
Y es una pasión que creo que compartimos.
¿Tenés una lectura histórica de la frustración argentina
si existiese, viste?
La frustración, evidentemente, no.
No sucede por razones de nuestro ADN.
Muchas veces, parece, al escuchar algunos argumentos,
bueno, ¿qué es propio de los argentinos?
¿Cómo es el argentino? Me preguntan a mi quisi.
como somos muchos, como el argentino.
Sí, la historia es una cosa más compleja, no es que unos tipos tienen una DNA tal que
se hacen amigos de nuestros enemigos para salvarse personalmente, no, pero hay algunos
que lo hacen. Y otros que no lo hacen. Y a veces, en algunos países...
Las cosas ruedan por infinidad de sucesos y eso va dando lugar, esas fluctuaciones dan lugar a la realidad y por eso tratamos de explicar por otras cosas.
Pero es muy difícil explicar el destino argentino, que es complejísimo y como todo el destino nacional,
obedece a la interacción de numerosas fuerzas propias, internacionales, geográficas, climáticas.
Vos tenés hay una baulera de recursos donde uno va a agarrar lugares de, no sé si llamarlo de inspiración,
o de... o de pasión, ¿no? Hablabas de los griegos, hablabas de lo elénico, por ejemplo.
Pienso en tus cuentos, pienso en Oriente también, ¿viste? que China es como esa cosa así...
Y bueno, si esas son fuentes de inspiración, son...
Recursos que están ahí en los libros, desde luego, pero...
Están también en el pensamiento y en el recuerdo
Y creo que nos influyen, creo que nos influyen siempre.
Sí, tengo. Todo lo que me aprendí es una fuente de inspiración y algún modo uno
tiende a apropiarse de todo lo que ha leído, como si fuera propio. Y creo que con cierto
con derecho. Con derecho, ¿no? Yo creo que con cierto derecho.
lo que uno ha leído, lo que uno ha sabido, lo que le han contado a sus mayores, lo que se han enterado ahí por la calle,
todo eso es propio, es propio.
Y de tanto andar entre malandras, de tanto leer,
si te hacen familiar en las historias de otro y te cuesta concebir que no son tuyas,
Pero de algún modo lo son.
¿Y algún modo lo son? ¿Por qué?
ir a buscar inspiración en Vítor Hugo,
el gusto enorme,
no Vítor Hugo Morales.
No, no, no, lo sé, lo sé.
Los miserables.
Claro.
No quiere decir copiar los capítulos,
pero quiere decir acordarse,
acordarse de un capítulo que se llama
las catacumbas de París.
Yo hoy voy a ser bien específico.
Entonces, voy a te acordar de ese capítulo.
Un capítulo larguísimo, estencísimo.
Fuera, casi fuera de la novela.
Te cuento todos los detalles de eso.
Eso te lo tenés en la cabeza y, un día,
se te ocurre un cuento que sucede
en las catacumbas de París.
O tenés el plano.
Y bueno, es que lo vayas a copiar a Vitorgo.
Si querés, no lo copies.
Empecé a estudiar sobre las catacumbas de París.
¿Y qué? Escribirse algo que por ahí no tiene nada que ver con Vitorugo,
porque no está escrito de esa manera.
También es cierto que vos podés inspirarte
en técnicas estilísticas de Vitorugo, de la Martén o de Lugones,
que ha sido su seguidor.
Y bueno, está bien, si vos haces otra cosa con eso.
Está bien. ¿Por qué renunciar?
Oh, no, mira.
Y iba a escribir un cuento
sobre dos hermanos que se llevan mal,
pero imagínate que está la Biblia.
Sí, no, llegué tarde.
Claro, he llegado tarde. Bueno, no es esto, no.
Bueno, eso es muy propio.
Siento que eso es un poco patrimonio de la academia.
La investigación tiene esta cosa de rigor donde...
Y a este tema ya lo trató,
Tal, está este paper que habla de eso.
Me parece que la literatura...
¡Latémoslo de nuevo, a ver cómo lo hacémos!
¡Perfecto!
Bueno, Víctor Hugo.
Víctor Hugo creo que tiene, me acabo de acordar,
una de las definiciones más hermosas para las iglesias
que yo leí en mi vida, que creo que las llama
lugares de observación del infinito.
Son espacios que el hombre dedica
a contemplar el infinito.
está muy bien, está muy bien eso. Fascinante. En ciertos casos la arquitectura favorece
muchísimo esa contemplación, los góticos debieron haber leído a Vitorú. Claro. Con
antelación. Es espectacular, pero yo siento, viste, vuelvo a lo de creer, siento que todo
está un poco atravesado. Si no crees no puedes hacer una obra de arte, me parece.
Se puede hacer una obra de arte de septicismo.
Sí, claro. Las mejores.
Las mejores.
Y eso no es un poco...
¿No le pertenece a los refutores de leyendas?
Claro.
No puede ser. Se me está quemando...
NO!!!
No bueno bueno
Únicamente un loco es un refutador es un hombre sensible 100% yo creo que hay mezclas hay un ensayo de Aldo Huxley
si en que yo no me acuerdo ahora qué clasificación hace bueno es que son los tipos
y los otros nombres supogamos espiritual espiritualidad
estoy diciéndolo mal, pero poner espiritualidad, tipo...
del medio y carnalidad.
Entonces, él dice que todos nosotros tenemos un número de
proporción.
Ponéle que tengamos en total 5 puntos.
Entonces, usted tiene 3, 2, 1.
Entonces, serían 6, dice.
Bueno, 3, 1, 1.
y así. Tres de espiritualidad, uno de musculatura y uno de carnalidad. Pero dice que el 5-0
solamente los locos.
quiere decir que todos somos un poco refutadores de leyenda
y otros pocos hombres sensibles.
Y está bien eso.
Yo soy hombre sensible para desear, para querer,
para amar, para soñar.
Y refutados de leyenda, lo saco cuenta.
Sí.
Si no pagas con imaginación, ¿no?
Sí, quería poner ahí.
¿Cuál es tu porcentaje?
en tu tabla de refutador.
y de hombre sensible. ¿Cuánto hay de... Es buena, ¿eh?
Muy buena. La respuesta honesta sería que no lo sé, pero poné 3-2.
3-2.
Primero refutador, segundo hombre.
Y un poquito más refutador.
Un poquito más refutador.
Es terrible.
Sí, claro.
Me han ido, me han ido acorralando.
sacando el margen, uno arranca. Me han ido empujando que quiere que le diga. Yo cuando
llegué aquí a este barrio era 4-1, hombres son siglos. Y después vinieron a escuchar
tangos. Claro, a no sacar premios en la galantería. Es así. Muchos desengajos.
Bueno, es verdad, es verdad, si el desengaño no fuese una fuente de arte, no tendríamos tango.
No, claro, todo lo malo que uno le ocurre es la poesía.
La poesía se nutre de la falta más que de la sobra, se nutre de lo que no hay.
Hay un ensayo de Borges que no está en las obras completas.
Creo que está en un libro que se llama El Tamaño de mi Esperanza.
Y hay un ensayo acerca de la escasis de literatura de la felicidad.
Y dice que los versos que cuentan como un tipo de feliz son menos y son peores.
¿Recuerda?
Aquel verso de Fráil Luis de León, el que dice,
despiérteme las aves con su cantar suave no aprendido,
no los cuidados graves de que siempre es seguido quien
del ajeno arbitrio está tenido.
Bueno, él dice que quiero esto y no aquello,
¿Pero más?
hacia lusión de lo que le molesta y entonces ya no es un verso que cuenta su felicidad sino
que cuenta la ausencia de desdicha. Cuidado. Y dice Borges yo creo que con razón que la
mayoría de los versos felices, lo que cuentan es que no estás mal, no que estás bien.
No estoy enfermo, no estoy preocupado por la fama y el dinero.
Él cuenta en la no desdicha, muy bien.
En cambio, los que cuentan la felicidad en formas positivas son poquísimos
y no tan buenos.
los mejores versos son aquellos en donde se ha perdido.
Se ha perdido la juventud, se ha perdido la esperanza, se ha perdido un amor,
se ha perdido la justicia, se ha perdido la patria.
Y esos son versos tremendos y conmovedores.
de que está bien, hay algunos, pero no sé si son tan buenos.
¿Será porque se torna justamente más necesario en esos momentos?
¿Son momentos donde vos estás mal, recurrirse a un poema?
Yo creo que es porque la naturaleza humana es trágica, antes que nada es trágica, antes que nada.
Y el poeta, además del conocimiento de su arte,
así debe conocer las palabras como las palabras se buscan se miran se acarician se tocan se rechazan
Pero toda poesía implica un juicio acerca de la naturaleza humana.
Y si no, no es una poesía.
Y la naturaleza, siendo ésta trágica,
debía agregar.
¿Qué es lo que dice? No lo digo yo.
Octavio Paz, ¿no?
¿Vos sentís que en tu propia obra
los momentos de mayor calidad tienen que ver con oscuridades?
Sí.
Te eclaro.
Aquí no hay otra cosa, creo, porque incluso cuando es gracioso es gracioso, pero porque está describiendo oscuridad.
Es tremendo eso.
Claro que es tremendo, ¿qué se cree?
Es la vida esto, no una que armé ese, dijo el tipo.
Pero aún así hay tiempo, no, no, no te preocupes.
No, no hay manera, no puedes ahora rematar.
Me gano, si es que… Me gano, si es que…
¡Hjorita tovina igual!
Y yo no puede ser dichoso por momentos.
Por momentos.
Por momentos que quieres, todo el tiempo.
No, no, y sí, no. No se puede, no se puede.
Es espectacular, pero y creo que es
es lo que se nota acá para mí, o sea, tiene que ver con eso mismo.
Tiene que ver con ese mismo encuentro.
A vos te ha pasado, o sea, me imagino que sí, o sea, preguntar si alguna vez la
pasaste mal es una pelotude, es quien nunca la pasó mal.
Pero alguna vez te encontraste lo que uno diría hoy deprimido o como agarrar.
Sí, ahora.
en este momento, en este mismo momento, en este instante, en esta conversación, ya que me lo preguntas.
¿Estás mal? ¿Estás triste?
Sí, claro, sí, sí, sí.
¿Por qué estaría contento?
Por...
No, sí, sí, sí.
Es un momento...
probablemente patológico también.
Me debe pasar lo mismo que a mis compañeros de colegio.
el mismo grupo que decías.
Sí, me pasa exactamente lo mismo, solo que yo no me doy cuenta,
y me creo que a mí no me pasa, pero tal vez me pasa.
Y es que está la principal tragedia que es que uno toma con ciencia su finitud.
Bueno, uno quiere vivir así en primas, mirad qué cosa es esto.
Te lo dice uno que sospecha que está de al primero.
La vida es hermosa.
La vida es hermosa, quiero vivir siempre, quiero estar siempre aquí.
Eso ya es un motivo tristeza, ¿no?
Pero si a eso le agregamos la forma en que uno se conduele de lo que le pasa a los otros,
Los... los lazos.
fortísimos de amor que uno ha ido tejiendo durante toda su vida y la tristeza de ver
que algunas personas que uno ha amado están fracasando en su intento por vivir, por disfrutar,
encontrar su lugar en este mundo.
Todo eso tiene que llenar de
de perplijidad, de tristeza.
¿Y por qué no de depresión?
¿Hay?
Hay algo, sin embargo,
en la misma condolencia,
en la misma tristeza que uno
le produce el mal ajeno.
¿Hay algo misterioso?
Se lo diría que nos redime.
Pero que nos deje un sentimiento parecido al que revelaba el overdande Senankur, que era un personaje,
que decía que si la nada es lo que nos espera después de la muerte,
vivamos tratando de hacer que esto sea una cosa injusta.
Perseverar en el amor y en la composición de Mironga.
y en el abrazo divertido de nuestros amigos, y en el deseo.
Es una manera de...
en antecerla, cuando dice un humano,
si es que uno sabe que se va a morir.
Y, fíjate, no dirán, esta especie, que es la única que sabe
que se va a morir en...
y yo digo, bueno, ahí están.
Miren, es un baile, están bailando, se están riendo.
Hay pocos caminos para seguir, pero valen la pena.
El arte, el amor, el conocimiento.
Qué más querido.
Es un montón.
Es un montón, un montón.
Ahora...
Hay también quienes se están a favor de lo que están en contra.
Quiero decir, ya la condición humana es trágica, pero el ser humano también viene, viene
el osurro, ¿no?
Hay tipos que aumentan, hay congéneres que aumentan la tragedia de pertenecer a esta
pese a
Lo que podríamos llamar la malevolencia, no sé cómo llamar, pero la bondad y el fracaso te llenan de ternura y la violencia, la malevolencia te llenan de desesperanza.
¿Has conocido vos así de primera mano, lo que dirías malevolencia?
Sí. Sí, sí, lo he visto.
¿Las combatido?
Me ha alejado de ella, por lo general.
Cuando pude, la he combatido, pero no he podido con ella.
No, pero yo he visto.
Yo he conocido personas verdaderamente malas, violentas.
Verdadero mal parido.
difícil. Y no estoy hablando de teorías.
A tu propia vida, tu propia experiencia. Yo estoy hablando de criminales.
Se ha conocido, he tratado de apartarme de su camino.
Sí, capaz, se trata un poco de eso, no sé si uno... pa, no sé, no sé.
Siento que tocamos los abismos que te vuelven la mirada, es la impresión que
lo que hay que hacer, lo que hay que hacer, lo que hay que hacer.
hay algo de eso en este momento te quería preguntar algo igualmente la maldad pura no
es fácil de percibir porque solamente es efectiva cuando hay poder a lo mejor yo soy
el tipo más malo del mundo pero como no tengo poder nadie se lo cuenta y qué mal puedo hacer yo
El tema es cuando alguien muy malvado
Tiene mucho poder, y entonces ahí los males que pueden generar son cósmicos.
En cambio, un verdulero malo, por ejemplo,
eh, que nos puede vender frutas en mal estado.
Puede afectar un par ahí.
por ahí te faja, porque lo miraste mal, pero un príncipe maloado es mucho más peligro.
A vos te ha pasado en una vida de influencia de cierta, de notoriedad, ¿no?, de un montón de cosas.
¿Le pasaste como muy elegantemente esta idea de estar construyendo medio...? ¿Qué términos usaste?
¿Que no era la edificación que querías construir? ¿Que a veces quizás eras convidado a algo que de repente decías esto y me pesega por otro lado?
¿Puiste conocer esos tipos de poder? ¿Cómo fue tu relación con el poder?
Casi nula, casi nula, ¿no?
muy pocas veces buscada por mí, no he tenido.
Porque, por ejemplo, para mí vos sos una persona que ha logrado,
no creo que exenta de tensión o problemáticas,
bueno, no sos un artista que agarra y no opina ni de la realidad ni de las cosas,
has tenido una relación con la historia política del espacio que compartiste,
de tu país, de la realidad.
Y eso muchas veces suele ser, te cito vos mismo en esta misma charla, cuando a racia
si es como te vas a perder a alguien, viste una obra, un lo que sea, por sus opiniones,
ya podemos sumar por su ideología.
Vos has transitado en ese sentido, una cornicia muy difícil porque es, yo te he escuchado
posicionarte una y mil veces y sin embargo no has quedado, creo, creo, capazos de lo
percibiris diferente, viste el famoso como encasillamiento, viste que hay una discusión
como del artista partidizado, por ejemplo.
Pero es que no, yo no tengo una vocación política.
A mí me interesa la política y me interesa mucho.
Y evidentemente, si me preguntan en contexto lo que pienso,
no es que no tenga ningún pensamiento político,
lo tengo y bastante perfilado.
Pero la política no forma parte de mis intereses personales.
No lo quiero ser político ni quiero.
Tener una carrera política ni nada que se les parezca.
Y si no he sido señalado por disposición política,
ha sido por mi ineficacia, por si lente,
ya que no he alcanzado a decir cosas
que puedan molestar a algunos.
¿Te ha tensado en alguna oportunidad?
ha sido como un problema de...
Pero también le digo que no espero nada tampoco, no espero ninguna alegría que provenga de así.
Tendría derecho entonces a esperar que ninguna tristeza saliera de su lugar.
Y eso es capaz de ser más difícil.
Lo que quiero decir es que yo no he estado en mucho de nuestro foro, soy amigo de algunos tipos,
generalmente por casualidad, y todo el mundo sabe que soy peronista, pido permiso y nada más.
Pero ella parecía una frase que se me atribuye, que se pantosa.
¿Cuál? Dice muchas, pero ésta es especialmente insidiosa porque dice
dejemos de pedir perdón, dejemos, somos nosotros los peronistas, ¿no?
Dejemos de pedir perdón cuando uno de nosotros comete un delito, un delito.
Durísima la frase. Pero eso no es nada con la que sigue.
Ellos no tienen a ninguna persona honesta.
punto. Alejandro Dorni.
Me suena.
Yo una vez creo que...
Yo no me veo a mí pensando eso, pero ni aunque tuviera razón.
Es buenísimo, dejémeme ir para lo por nuestros delitos y ese espectaculo.
Porque ellos no tienen ni uno que sea honesto.
Cosa, ¿no?
Bueno, por ahí no me das, mí.
No me da por eso, por eso.
Por esa concepción, jamás votaría un liberal, pero jamás lo acusaría de ser deshonesto por ser liberal,
o al menos hasta que me expliquen cómo es la cosa.
Hasta que se entiendan, digo, también.
Yo no digo que no haya que castiguarda.
Ahora, 20 minutos de explicaciones, pero no soy de la policía.
Bueno, volviendo a la frase que vos citabas,
siendo inocente no tirando la piedra igual, hay algo...
¡Ahí está!
Sí, sí.
Bueno, ahí esto será para bien, para mal, pero te tendrás que hacer cargo también.
Cuando digo que me hace influido no miento, yo recuerdo en la búsqueda de mis...
Tengo varias búsquedas también.
Creo que comparto... Has hecho una gran disección de horizontes,
porque vos hablaste del conocimiento, el amor y el arte, ¿no?
como.
Son como todos grandes nortes, una vida dedicada a eso es un privilegio si uno puede hacerlo
en esos términos, pero también me parece que es una vida que vale la pena ser vivida
y es un montón.
Yo recuerdo cuando estaba buscando alguna de las dimensiones de quién era, una de las
cuales era política, yo también soy peronista, pero también soy peronista por vos, entre
otras cosas.
Bueno, entonces estamos arreglados.
Sí, por supuesto.
Yo recuerdo dos cosas.
Yo sé, pero no está por vos también, así que...
de retroalibés. Me parece que estamos cometiendo un error cósmico. Y bueno, a uno de los tienen
que ser convencidos primero, digamos. Yo me acuerdo... Ay, era buenísima. Obviamente
la voy a atribuir y va a ser difícil de desmentir, pero me acuerdo dos cosas. Siempre me acuerdo
cuando una vez te preguntaron por Borges.
gorilas y los hay, ¿no? Los ilustres gorilas y te preguntaban pero cómo puedes
disfrutar de Borges siendo peronista y te voy a citar mal, pero dijiste pose peronista
pero no boludo digamos, creo que lo dijiste mucho más elegante, creo que...
¡Habe dicho estúpido!
Y la otra que fue fascinante, porque hace así discusiones yo pasé por etapas más
así de sobre intelectualizar las cosas y creo que estoy casi seguro que te lo
escuché decir en algún lado que vos dijiste mi se peronista porque quería
mantener mis ideales pero quería comprarme un auto.
Quería disfrutar de...
No, esa no la recuerdo.
Esa no.
Esa no la recuerdo.
Yo nunca quería comprarme algo.
Ah, mirad.
Era como...
No, no.
Yo tenía...
especialmente siendo joven...
unos sueños económicos...
diferentes, diferentes.
No sé si quería bienes.
¿Qué querías?
Algunos eran capaces de trabajar mucho con tal de adquirir hirvianas y yo trabajaba para comprarme el ocio para comprarme tiempo.
Buenísimo.
Quería tener tiempo para mí, entonces buscaba esos trabajos.
¿Y para qué? Para trabajar en lo que yo quería ser gratis.
Conseguiste tiempo.
Conseguí, hasta conseguí que me pagaran por aquello que, gustosamente, haría gratis.
Tiempo, querían. Tiempo. Igual lo malgasté ese tiempo, ¿no?
Ese tiempo que me compré, lo malgasté leyendo novelas policiales baratas,
frecuentando amigos que...
que quizá no eran tan beneficiosos, ¿quién sabe eso?
¿Para qué te sirve? ¿Qué ventaja tenés?
Es una manera equivocada de mirarlo todo.
¿Qué ganas con esos tipos en el esquín hablando?
No se trata de ganar.
Él dijo que quiero ganar. Quiero ganar nada.
Quiero estar ahí, quiero ver. Quiero ver qué pasa.
Quiero ver qué pasa, a ver si...
Si en una de esas se parece algún estímulo verdadero.
Pero ver, jamé ver, jamé ver.
Uno cuando es muy joven, tiene demasiada fe en sus amigos, es cierto.
Pero es inevitable, es así, es así.
Uno tiene amigos en la juventud, nada más, después no.
de bueno.
Después le quedan a uno los amigos que comparten la profesión o el arte o los sueños, eso sí, ¿no?
Los músicos que tocan con uno son amigos, sí, son amigos.
La armonía está hecha para eso, ¿no?
Para que uno entienda lo que es la amistad.
Pero si no, uno tiene amigos cuando es joven,
es amigo grande, ¿cómo le va Don Fulano?, ¿qué sé yo?, ¿qué sé yo?
son creo que los de la juventud son esos únicos grupos que son más de
contingencia que otra cosa no sé si uno vuelve a generar esos amigos por por
estar verdaderamente vos lo decía vos dijiste algo muy poderoso para mí que es
a mis a mi grupo de amigos con los que me junto ahora ninguno va a ver esto
porque no les interesa mi vídeo.
profesional. Eso es un alivio. Eso, por lo menos a mí me pasa cuando yo me junto con mis amigos de
la secundaria, es no sé, de lo último que se trata es de si acá vino tal o cual es...
Pero se está muy cerca de la secundaria.
Sí, estoy muy cerca de la secundaria.
Pues, ¿estás todavía vosotros todavía el alumno que eras? No, no.
No, es que no puedo...
no sé cómo. No lo vea. Debe ser increíble. No lo vea. Y si uno piensa para atrás es mucho peor, ¿no?
Esas reuniones que se hacen de recordación. Hay de grupo, de acabada. Entonces yo pienso,
Yo pienso, imagínate la primaria, que ya es una época, ahí sí yo estoy seguro de hacer otro, otro en otro mundo.
Ah, es otro planeta.
Es otro planeta.
Entonces, uno se me dijo,
ay, lo voy a ver a Luisito Maldonado.
¿Quién es Luisito Maldonado?
Un niño de siete años que se sienta
a mi lado en el colegio.
Bueno, pero qué suerte.
Entonces, una espera en la esquina
y viene Luisito Maldonado.
Y no es un niño de siete años.
Y no un gran dulón pelado.
Yo no quiero eso.
No quiero eso.
es una obscenidad del tiempo.
Pero ¿qué puede hacer uno?
Bueno, buscar otra cosa, otra cosa.
Dejarse llevar por las corrientes del tiempo y encontrar otros
lucitos maldonados que también se sienten a nuestro lado,
ya con los intereses que tenemos ahora, que son distintos.
Hay algo muy poderoso del amigo que a veces siento con la salvedad de quedarme cerca.
Nosotros nos deliramos con que pasaron 10 años de algunas cosas.
Tenemos nuestras primeras anécdotas de hace 10 años y eso fue todo un...
Bueno, nada.
No es nada.
Bueno, 10 años no es nada.
Eso fue todo un impacto metafísico en nuestro grupo.
Fue como 10, hay 10, dos cifras, no puede ser.
Si es por el peor, ¿eh?
a veces me pasa que yo siento que ellos son como el amigo termina siendo como un
testigo de la propia vida porque hay algo de que es verdad que uno cambia con
el tiempo bienvenido sea que uno cambia y que ellas esos son los únicos
personas que pueden corroborar que yo haya sido esa misma persona pero claro
supuestamente tienen tienen porque son testimonios fehacientes de que
que vos, con toda tu compadrada de hoy,
yo soy el tipo que una vez se digeras y vos
en el acto del 25 de mayo.
Exactamente.
Y lo cuentan y te lo enrostran.
Es su deber.
Es su deber darte estimoño de aquel pasado.
Por eso son gente tan peligrosa.
Fundamental.
Voy a ver si yo a caceros.
actuar. En realidad voy al palomar, no importa, pero tomemos como si esto fuera cierto.
Hacemos giras nosotros con el programa, por ahí voy a Casiros, que es el lugar donde yo me cridé,
los viví mis niñas, etcétera.
Y no hay mucha repercusión, quiero decir, los que vienen a verme son gente que no me conoció nunca.
que les da lo mismo si son así en castellero, o dónde.
Y sin embargo, yo no dejo de hacerme la ilusión
de que van a ir mis viejos amigos en Tropel.
No, por ahí va alguno.
Pero además me encuentro con algo que esto es lo que yo quería contar.
Uno tenía, como yo he sido un pibe bastante atorrante.
bastante malvisto por la comunidad, por los macanúdicos de Casel y teníamos nuestros
enemigos, viejos malos, personas que eran intolerantes con los muchachos, que odiaban
un poco, toda estudiantina.
Así se llaman, con los nombres de esos viejos, de miércoles,
están bautizadas las calles de Casero.
Y si quién es este tipo, fulano ganombrano, fulaneto de talud...
Los conocés en las calles.
Es alucinante eso.
Algo uno, por supuesto que hay algunos.
Otros ilustres.
Era gente maravillosa.
Por si y a lo todo.
Vamos a decir no es género.
Es espectacular eso, poder...
Bueno eso es una locura.
que tiene su costado como ya ha señalado trágico, el componente trágico.
es el método más trágico hasta ahora.
Hay un nivel de profundidad en términos de arte y de estilo
que me parece que hay que destacar.
Pero también hay enormes privilegios.
O sea, vos conociste a Borges, vos...
Sí, claro, señor.
Eso es una locura.
No, lo conocí.
No importa.
No es que él me dijera que dice como levado, lina,
¿qué está escribiendo ahora?
A mi me estaba ahí.
Me decía, buenas tardes, ¿qué tal?
Y nada más.
Y yo tampoco le decía nada más.
Buenas tardes, señor.
Y nada más, yo fui el único colado admitido en una serie de entrevistas que hizo Antonio Carrillo
a Borges en el ochenta, en el ochenta.
¿Por qué colado? ¿Qué te metiste ahí?
¿Por qué qué tenía que hacer yo? Ahí estaba colado, estaba ahí colado, me dejaban asistir
y yo pagaba ese privilegio, no hablando, no decía nada, sueltamente nada.
Pero si lo conocí, quiere decirlo bien en acción.
Lo vi en acción, lo vi hablar, lo vi pensar, lo vi dudar, lo vi decidir una palabra en vez de otra.
Lo vi explicar, lo vi reírse, lo vi decir malas palabras.
Qué lindo eso.
Sí, claro.
Ah, es un privilegio.
Es un privilegio.
Sí, sí, seguro.
Y creo que...
Además, sí, sí.
Un privilegio en lo nominal, pero también en lo real.
porque era un hombre que hacía honor al expectativo que despertaba.
No hay que hacer mucho caso a los que lo imitan, a los imitadores que hacen una voz vacilante,
que nadie vaya a creer que tenía que nombrar nada de vacilante.
Era un hombre que tenía unas maneras de hablar,
pero tenía un pensamiento
Lúcio, genial.
Ordenado, infalible.
Ah, es infalible.
Eso es infalible.
Infalible.
A mí me pasa, bueno, Borges es un tópico en sí mismo, ¿no?
Pero, perdón, pregunta de rigor.
¿Cómo estamos de tiempo?
Una hora 40.
Una hora 40, hablamos.
Pensé que era mucho menos.
¿Vos estás bien?
No estoy bien, pero no por esta razón.
no por estas razones.
Claro. Y en general...
Ay, Dios. No, bueno...
Seguimos un rato más. Seguimos un rato más, hermoso, me encanta.
Eh...
Yo quería tomar un poco de líquido.
Hagamos ahí un refil. ¿Y la coca es coca?
Pensé que era vino y medio no se quiera purado.
Es coca, pero capaz está medio muerta. Podemos recambiar por algo más fresco.
Está perfecta. Bien.
A mí me gusta la coca-cola floja, los mates lavados.
Bien, eso sí, que le compartimos cuando lo quiera.
eh?
que también, salvándolos espejismo, para mí vos sos un continuador de esa tradición del
río La Plata, entre mí y los literarios, eso es así, también te lo quería decir personalmente,
teniendo yo un privilegio en esta oportunidad.
los textos finales de Borges
También tienen profundidades aterradoras.
Viste que Borges se encuentra dos veces con
sigo mismo, se encuentra una vez en un banco de plaza y se encuentra otra vez.
Este es menos citado, el último es menos citado,
pero es terrible el último porque se encuentra.
No lo tengo presente.
En el último cuento, que creo que es en su última colección de cuentos,
él se vuelve a encontrar a sí mismo y medio.
No quiero decir con un pie en el cajón, pero se encuentra el mismo tirado en una cama, ¿viste?
Ajá, no conozco ese texto.
Ah, es impresionante, que hace que lo...
No me acuerdo cómo se llama el título, pero debe ser muy fácil de encontrar.
Y es en el título, es en el cuento que él advierte, con mucha preocupación,
algo que para mí es artísticamente impresionante cómo lo define,
que es que el teme, me parece que puede ser la palabra teme,
Estar empezando a convertirse en una imitación del propio Borges.
Como la idea de tener un estilo, o sea, haber encontrado su voz, un estilo,
y él empezar a sacar textos, en el cuento relata que empieza a sacar textos,
sin firmarlos y que la crítica lo revienta, porque dice que es una imitación de Borges, pero sin su gracia.
Y es terrible.
No, no, es ciertamente que no conozco ese texto, y lo quiero conocer ya porque es la idea fortísima.
¡Es fortísima! ¡Lasso pecha!
de convertirse en uno en su propia parodia.
Claro, la imitación de uno mismo, haber encontrado uno.
Bueno, como para que salgas peor.
Que no me parecen muchas veces eso.
Uno lo notan los demás.
El gente que por ahí decae, incluso físicamente,
de algún modo, la malevolencia general dice que
Pularnos una parodia a sí mismo, pero descubrirlo uno.
en su propia persona, es tremenda.
No, es que eso es lo que tiene. Te lo quería citar
porque me hizo acordar esta cosa de reencontrar un lugar
indudablemente es Borges,
pero te lo vuelves a encontrar como... ¿Buscaron algo?
¿Vas a ver?
No, no, porque el otro es el primer encuentro.
Sí, el primer.
El otro es el primer encuentro.
Y entonces no sé.
Lo voy a buscar, pero si no, muy rápidamente lo vamos a poder encontrar.
Si no es un cuento, es uno de los ensayos del final, pero es el último, ¿viste?
Es de la última colección.
Y me hizo acordar esto, me hizo acordar a cómo uno revisita su propia obra
y se encuentra cada vez más complicado.
Y ahí volvemos a lo terrible de la literatura, ¿no?
Como agarrar y es efectivamente el lugar donde uno más desnudo está.
Yo creo que como la mayoría de las cosas Borges lo hace mejor.
Entonces vos lo agarras y lo encontras y si...
que manera tremendamente correcta de expresar esto que uno podría temer en algún lugar.
Es cierto que hay también una influencia del entorno para que uno vuelva a escribir siempre el mismo poema.
Eso es interesante.
En estas mismas charlas que hacemos nosotros podemos notarlo en una persona tan poco interesante como yo.
Pero yo veo algunas entrevistas que me han hecho y aparecen.
Aparecen ejemplos que yo doy, que son mi responsabilidad.
Pero también asuntos que aparecen y reaparecen y vuelven y vuelven,
que tal vez no decido yo, pero lo decide el conductor o la
la circunstancia de la conversación.
Ya me va a ver un temor, no pensará el tipo que estaba yendo esta charla, que yo siempre digo lo mismo.
Es posible que uno diga siempre lo mismo.
¿Cómo salirse uno de esa rueda de palabras, de frases, de gracias?
Y yo creo que hay que tomarse el trabajo, que hay que tomarse el trabajo de aprenderse
nuevas canciones.
¿Qué es lo que hace que uno se repita?
En principio, la finitud de los anunciados.
En tal caso, la única solución es dotarse de anunciados nuevos.
Pero eso hay que seguir leyendo, que seguir aprendiendo,
luchando contra eso, contra eso.
Tampoco me simpatiza tanto la persona que parece tener en cada entrevista
interesan nuevos.
para que están las obsesiones y no para repetirla.
y, como decía Sábado, por ahí es entendible que un escritor tenga sus obsesiones, como las tenía Borges,
obsesiones que van a aparecer en casi toda su obra, y en eso está bien, que lo repitamos.
Cuando me preguntan algún asunto sobre mi obra, digo yo, mi obra, sobre estas cosas que uno hace,
Evidentemente que hay asunto. Esto del amor, el conocimiento, ya lo repetí como 500 veces.
Por ahí la gente lo escucha y dice, este siempre habla de lo mismo.
En ese caso no es tan grave, pero si yo empiezo a contar siempre la misma anécdota graciosa,
y sería deseable que la cambiara cada tanto.
Al respecto, también hay que alertar sobre el peligro de las anécdotas graciosas.
¡Ay!
personajes mediáticos que son buenos contando anécdotas y que tienen un montón de anécdotas así
como otros tienen un montón de pensamientos o un montón de testimonios históricos,
filosóficos, literarios, etcétera. Hay tipo de saber anécdotas. Desde luego son muchos más
requeridos que los otros.
Contadores de anécdotas son mejores para el rating que los que citan de memoria a Borges.
Yo no sé si es tan bueno eso de la anécdota, no, yo he renunciado a contar anécdotas.
Renunciaste las cosas.
Sí, sí, no, muy raro, pero yo cuente algunas.
No tiene mucha gracia.
Pero hay que tener, hay que tener una habilidad, evidentemente yo no tengo, ¿no?
Hay que usurpar un personaje, hay que hablar un poco más fuerte, ¿no?
Y hay que fingir un entusiasmo por la amistad
y las noches de copas que uno no siente.
Entonces viene el tipo y me dice
y que cosa y no puedo
No puedo interesarme en eso.
Es que creo que hay una cosa de la forma, vuelvo a lo mismo, ¿no?
Yo creo que todo, gran parte de lo que hablamos está atravesado por encontrar esa renovación,
esa innovación en la propia búsqueda incluso.
Porque el arte también es encontrar esa innovación dentro de lo genuino que uno es,
para no impostarse, ni para no mentirse tampoco, para no ser otra cosa.
Es extremadamente difícil, pero ahí está la calidad.
Porque si haces eso bien, es lo que hace que el resto de cosas valga la pena.
La négota no deja de ser un lugar común, un lugar seguro.
También entiendo, o sea,
hablamos de Borges. Borges lo señala al respecto de uno mismo.
Me nota una imitación y él trata de escapar de eso.
Tremenda manera de evocar una propia prisión artística.
Pero, verdad...
Pero uno al día.
Así aportamos algo también de acá
vos aportas otra cosa, que es real que si a los Rolling Stone le piden los mismos temas siempre.
y entonces hay algo de la solución es tocar cada tanto los mismos temas y tocar también otros
volvemos a la cuestión de grado del equilibrio de un poquito refutador
Y, de nuevo, volverse una repetición, un calco.
Yo empatizo completamente con la cuestión de las notas, ¿viste?
A mí me está pasando últimamente que la gente cree que yo soy un hortiva,
para decirlo fácil, porque me invitan a dar notas,
y yo digo que las reprogramo para dentro de cuatro meses,
entonces rápidamente me dicen quién poronga te pensas que son,
con justicia igual, porque yo quiero agradecer ese espacio y esa posibilidad.
Pero no quiero aburrir, lo que me está pasando en este momento, o sea, si uno da cinco notas,
es la persona que... La cuarta persona que vio las tres lo estafaste.
Sí.
Lo cagaste.
Sí, sí, sí.
Rompiste tu contrato con...
con quien te banca en serio, además, porque ese que vio las tres, entonces...
Claro, claro.
Es el que importa.
No sé cómo uno escapa de eso, pero me parece que en esa misma búsqueda...
No, no, no, no da nota.
¿Qué es la nota? Es una trampa.
A mí no me gustan...
No es que no me gusten, que no sé cómo contestarlas.
Las notas colectivas.
¿Cuáles son las notas colectivas?
Las notas colectivas, ahí...
Junto conmigo vienen...
siete personas.
Ok.
Hablábamos, y si hace una pregunta general y todos conté, ni habla.
No sé qué decir, yo ahí opto por no decir nada, soy el séptimo tipo del que no dice nada.
Y bueno, no sé.
¿Observa?
No, no es que observa, me da miedo meterme, ¿qué es eso?
Está bien.
Sí, eso no me curte.
Bueno, espero que, que, a mí, mirá, yo te voy a hacer, ¿eh?
¡No, no!
Es capaz, ya es hora de, bueno, me parece perfecto.
Igual hemos promediado un gran tiempo, un muchísimo.
Yo tengo que hacer los honores de presentar a nuestro glorioso equipo de trabajo.
Por favor.
tengo también, voy a hacerte la última confesión de la jornada.
que es que, por supuesto, yo estaba de vuelta a un sentido de responsabilidad para que esto sea agradable.
Y yo traté de informarme, ¿no?, con confidentes, con una serie de personas,
las cuales yo tengo acceso, que no es tanto, y preguntarles, ¿no?
Ve, che, mirá, va venido Lina, ¿cómo la ves?
Le pregunté a Barton y le pregunté a Felipe Piña.
¿Qué le preguntó?
Le pregunté y dije, mirá, che, va venido Lina.
¡Qué sabe!
Se te ocurre algo, se te ocurre algo, algo para, para.
le dije, esto creo que estaría bueno hablar,
esto creo que no estaría bueno hablar,
como yo me informé y traté de...
Y Barton me dijo, no te puedo decir nada.
Lo cual es...
¡Muy buena respuesta!
Y luego a quemar.
Y claro.
Y ahí lo vas a arrastrear.
Entonces prefirió que no decía nada.
Disciplina, pero...
¿Y piña qué dijo?
Piña fue mucho más inquietante.
Porque el Philip...
Ya me lo sospechaba.
Mira, el Philip me dijo...
Todo me dijo, no, va a estar buenísimo.
Pero, pero el Philip me dijo...
No le preguntes boludeses.
Con eso me liquidó.
Entendés, porque yo le digo...
Pero, Felipe, escucháme, estás dando una edad.
No en la primera respuesta que yo puedo dar.
Está dando con términos una policía mi amplia, le digo. Es un poco mi metid, aparte.
Así que tú es la asesoría, una que fue por ausencia y otra que fue una advertencia,
viste, más tremenda en general.
No, no, no, están mal las dos.
Pero creo que las boludeces y ni miedades son el campo donde son mejor me desempeen.
Son un buen campo, boludeces.
Es un trabajo.
Es un argumento.
Y en cuanto a la negativa absoluta de Barton tampoco me extraña porque es un hombre que elude responsabilidad.
Mira, bueno, perfecto, listo.
Lo atendemos ahí.
Este es otro, un anécdoto.
Estamos nosotros, yo soy un hombre de otra época que he hecho el servicio militar en la marina.
Entonces, en cierta ocasión compartíamos con siete amigos una formidable sesión de disciplina.
que los infantes de Marina nos hacían correr para aquí, para allá.
Y hay un momento de descanso,
y estábamos ahí los amigos hablando o algo.
Nada, no estábamos sentiendo nada.
Y viene alguien, suboficial de Infantería,
y nos dice ¿qué están haciendo ahí?
Descansando, subficial.
¿Por qué nos autorizó?
Es un descanso autorizado, descanso.
¿Cómo nos tienen a que hacer? No, no suficientemente.
¿Cuál partido de raso el Tío Alto Río empezaba?
¿Qué hizo? ¿Carrera mal para qué?
¿Por qué? ¿Por qué preguntaban todos?
Y el tipo nos mira y nos dice,
por eludir responsabilidades.
extraordinario, extraordinario.
de este hombre.
Inquietante también.
Claro, extraordinaria por inquietante, no se crea que yo estoy a favor del tipo, pero
no encontraba ningún delito, ninguna infracción, ninguna cosa, y pensó que esa especie de inocencia
implicaba la ilusión de responsabilidades.
Y esto es lo que le estoy.
enrostrando a Patricio Barton.
¡Perfecto!
Y ya, aparente discripción,
consiste en eludir responsabilidades
que debió haber asumido.
Es una omisión de hecho.
Pero claro que sí.
Perfecto, espectacular.
Me temo que esta charla ha sido también,
de mi parte, un continuo eludir responsabilidad.
No creo, ¿eh?
Si yo he descubierto, miren, no hago muchas.
Muchos descubrimientos acerca de mí mismo, porque trato de que el objeto de estudio sea más interesante, pero que a veces estoy buscando la tercera respuesta, ya casi como una metodología, que le gusta frío o caliente.
Es más complejo.
es más complejo que eso, es refutador de leyendas o ese hombre sencillo, ¡eh, no!
Bueno, contestadme alguna en serio. Contestadme alguna en serio. Dirá el tipo que está escuchando este programa.
Que si alguien busca eso, ¿por qué lo busca?
Porque seguramente nos escuchan muchos occidentales.
y el modo occidental requiere una toma de partido.
El héroe occidental es un tipo que toma partido, se la juega, dirían los analistas políticos.
Y entonces siempre contesta en forma positiva.
¿Con quién estás?
¿Con Hillel Clinton?
¿O con Bush?
No, fulano, fulano.
Y ahí aparece Roland Barth, que dice...
que hay que salirse de ahí y que hay un libro que se llama
Lo Neutro creo, es un libro maravilloso de Roland Barthes
y dice que por ahí hay que examinar cada pregunta
y la mayoría de las veces rechazar sus términos
porque contestar significa aceptar los términos de la pregunta
Y eso es una buena enseñanza de Roland Barth.
para el pensamiento político porque no se trata de una tibieza para quedarse en el medio,
Se trata, dice él, de suspender el juicio.
de no abrir un juicio, de negarse, no suspenderlo por no comprometerse, sino al contrario por
comprometerse con una suspensión del juicio cuando la pregunta nos parece que tiene unos
términos inaceptables. No está mal esto para pensar los términos en que se contestan
los reportajes.
es mantener el desafío también.
No deja de ser innovar, no deja de ser lo mismo que todo.
Nunca renunciar a que se pueda encontrar.
Buscar otro camino.
Es un hecho artístico.
¿Qué sé yo? Si es...
refutador de leyenda...
o hombre...
Si alguien puede agarrar e impugnar el prisma,
eso es vos, es agarrar y decir, no sabes qué es.
en el que rompes el libro.
rompes el libro. Y eso y cualquier otra cosa. Y eso y cualquier otra cosa. Hay que buscar otro camino.
Y a lo mejor ahí está la única esperanza en un desierto desesperanzador. Buscar. Buscar otra cosa.
para darse cuenta de que esa otra cosa no era otra.
Un día conversaremos sobre esto, por ejemplo, la locura del enamorado que quiere volver
al hombre o a la mujer que lo ha abandonado y llora por esa mujer y quiere encontrarla de nuevo o por ese hombre.
y a lo mejor la búsqueda tiene que estar en otro lado.
Encontrar la mujer que nos dejó en otra mujer,
en otra historia, en otro tiempo.
y para darse cuenta al final de que no era distinto el asunto,
de que eso que buscábamos era lo mismo que perdimos, pero que lo hemos encontrado.
En otro lugar, porque es otro tiempo, porque uno es otro
y porque no hay otra posibilidad de encontrar lo que hemos perdido.
que en otros lugares, que no son aquellos en donde extravíamos lo que extravíamos.
Ahí es el paraíso perdido.
Los únicos que existen.
Ahí está.
Es hermoso.
Habiendo mucha finesa tan soltando.
A eso hay verdades sobre la hora.
Minuto 90, son todos goles.
Entran todos.
Voy a presentar al equipo nuestro con el que contamos.
Hemos mantenido nuestro staff en esta tercera temporada impresionante, impresionante.
Lo tengo Alarmenios Islian en los teclados AMO digital de nuestro diseño y compostura.
la tengo a Agus Santoro con nuevas atribuciones de producción, cada vez más responsabilidad.
Esperemos que con más distribución de riqueza también, ¿no?
Más poder.
Por supuesto.
Si de poder se trata, no puedo no nombrar a Lasus,
la productora ejecutiva de este ciclo con quien diseñamos,
creñamos, pensamos, nombramos los invitados,
hacemos ardides estrategias y todo lo que necesitamos para que
esto sea excelente y a trinidad Reboard que toma notas
compulsivamente, porque ni en este momento deja de trabajar
para que esto sea excelente y aún mejor.
¿Alguno de ustedes quiere viajar a algún lugar?
Sí, ¿saben qué? Hay una forma muy barata de viajar.
Sí, amigos.
Sí, hermano, y es con Turismo City.
Así lo hace un profesional, loco.
Y así recibimos nuestro primer sponsor.
¡Suscríbete! ¡Tres años tenemos reponsor!
turismo city papá no se van a olvidar nunca este PNT eso se llama Policiano
tradicional le digo para que lo anoten también nuevas generaciones
queridísimo Alejandro muchísimas gracias por todo estoy feliz sé que os
me aclaraste que no estás también en términos generales pero espero que lo
haya pasado bien espero que haya pasado bien claro que sí tomás y pido perdón
a los eventuales oyentes del programa por todo este tiempo.
que han perdido conmigo.
No, por favor.
Que podrían ver 4 o 5 episodios de la ley y el orden.
Por favor.
No sé de qué es una cosa de otro.
Esto quedará subido, pronto lo verán y reitero.
Muchísimas gracias por todo.
Gracias a vos.
Gracias por tu obra.
Gracias por todo.
Gracias a quienes vinieron también, gracias a quienes hacen esto posible.
Gracias a ustedes, Puerta Tercer Temporada.
Y vamos por todo, eh.
Aviso, miren que este año viene picante.
Vamos por absolutamente todo.
Decidme también, por supuesto, ¿cómo lo paraba?
Tomi, tranquilo, por favor, Tomi.
¿Cómo no vamos a hablar de corta?
¿Cómo no vamos a hablar del medio que también hace esto posible?
Entren a corta.com.
Ven como estamos, eh.
Hay que tener en cuenta todo, todo en la cabeza.
No hay nada notado.
Muchas gracias.
Nos vemos la semana que viene.
¿Con quién?
Veremos.
Adiós.